- The media stuff is so
shocking to me because I,
you know, I worked
at CNN for years
and I posted a couple shows
there or several shows there,
and then I, you know,
I was the main anchor
in MSNBC for four
years, I got fired.
But you know, I still
have a really good friend
who remain nameless,
who works there, still
a wonderful person,
really good guy,
and I have a couple
of friends at CNN.
So not a ton, two,
but anyway, but I know that
world really, really well.
And the biggest surprise for
me in one sentence is how
illiberal they are.
I always imagined
their liberal networks.
No, no, no, I'm liberal, okay?
In the sense that like,
I believe in the enlightenment
and I believe in
the bill of rights
and I think we do have rights.
They are not liberals.
They are defenders
of the powerful,
which is the much graver sin.
Like, you can have silly
politics, I get it.
I've had silly politics,
maybe I do now.
People make mistakes,
but defending the
billionaire class,
blaming everything on like
working class white people
who are like, you know,
by far the most shafted
people in America.
Look at the suicide rate,
look at the death rate.
I mean, it's like,
it's measurable,
but everything's their fault?
(bright music)
- I'm Dave Rubin
and joining me today
is the host of Tucker
Carlson Tonight on Fox News,
and the author of the new book,
"The Long Slide, 30 years
in American Journalism".
Tucker Carlson, welcome
back to the Rubin Report.
- Ladies and gentlemen,
thanks for having me, Dave.
- Tucker, you are
not in your studio,
you're not in a suit,
you appear to be in some
sort of secret bunker area
with books and pictures.
What's going on over there?
- I'm in my barn actually,
to be totally honest,
which is where I work.
I live in a rural area
in Northern New England
and we have an old
barn that we use for
everything basically.
To store the boats and
my wife has her Peloton and
we have our studio in it
and, you know, bunk
beds for people.
And so, yeah, I live in my barn.
- So you're kind
of living the dream
that you always wanted in a way.
I mean, a couple of years ago,
I've quoted this many times,
quoted you actually many times,
you walked into my house,
opened the door to my garage,
and I don't know if Fox News
is gonna want me to say
the exact thing you said,
but you basically said, holy
effin shiet, you've done it.
Meaning that I had
a studio at home
and I was able to
run my operation.
You've kind of expanded
into that world
while still maintaining
the mainstream cred.
- Well, yeah, I mean,
I have to say, I've
always believed
that what matters
is how you live.
You know, what's your life like?
What do you do when you wake up?
What time do you wake up?
Who do you wake up with?
I mean, those are the things
that define your life.
And so when I saw how you
lived, I thought, man,
this guy is really fair.
I mean, I know people
make a ton of money
who don't live anywhere
near as well as you do,
and I was just so
impressed by that.
And a confluence of
events happened and
we actually live in the town
that we've been in
our whole lives.
So it's not, we didn't
move anywhere weird,
this is where, you know,
we had a house here always
growing up, but why
not just move there?
And so we did and
it's been wonderful.
Yeah, and you were dealing
with some headaches
living in some other places
because, you know, obviously
the media matters, people,
and all the usual
trolls and everything.
They were sending people
to your house and,
you know, going out,
I mean, literally
like going after your wife
and kids and all that.
I know it's not fun
to talk about that,
but can you just talk
about it a little bit
just sort of relative to,
you're just trying to do
what you think is right
as a journalist and as
a personality and then
how it affects the life
and the people around you.
- Yeah, I mean, it was
just sad to see it happen.
I moved to Washington as a kid.
My dad worked for the
federal government
on the cold war,
and doing pretty honorable
things, I would say,
I think that anyway.
And so I've lived in Washington
essentially my whole adult
life, I mean since high school.
And it's a bipartisan town,
I mean, by definition,
both parties are represented,
both parties live there.
And as a result,
there's been this permanent
truce effectively for decades
where you can live next to
people you disagree with,
but you don't talk about
it at dinner parties,
you can be friends anyway.
And I love that environment,
a lot of my friends had
politics different from mine.
And then in 2016, Trump
was such a threat.
They were so worried,
not that Trump would
actually do anything,
and he really didn't
as well as we know,
but he said stuff and
he said obvious stuff.
And they were so terrified
that Trump was gonna point
out some really obvious things
about the way things
actually work,
that they were completely
threatened by him.
I mean, it really
It was like a foreign
power occupying the city
and the hatred, the bitterness.
And I just kind of agreed
with a lot of Trump's,
I don't know, ideas may be
a little strong, but themes,
you know, like when
you run the government,
you should always ask yourself,
is this helping the
people who live here,
who voted for me,
who paid for all of this,
whose country it is?
I really agree with
that and I always have.
So the division in
the city between
the overwhelming majority
of people who saw Trump
as this satanic figure
and the tiny minority
of us who were like,
well, yeah, okay, Trump,
whatever, you know, he's got
all these personal faults,
got it, but he's making
really good points.
Like, what is the
point of NATO.\?
I mean, just pick one
of a thousand examples.
Why shouldn't we
have a border wall?
You know, what about all those
people who died of fentanyl?
Like, what's the answer?
And all of a sudden,
it just became impossible
to live there and then,
you know, I've never lived
by negate or anything,
we live right on the
street in the city,
I raised my kids,
my four kids there,
and all of our dogs
and all this stuff,
and I felt like we were really
part of the city and then
next thing you know, people
are showing up at the house,
and you can sort of see
where this is going.
I mean, it's so threatening,
you know, where does it end?
You're gonna end up
shooting somebody,
and I don't wanna do that.
You know, I hate,
but that's where it's going.
You know, because
just living there
was so provocative to them,
having them show up
and threatened violence
against my family was so
threatening to me
that it just, it
wasn't gonna end well.
And I just thought,
and our fourth child went
off to boarding school
and we didn't have any kids
at home and sort of like,
well, wait, you know,
why don't we just move to where
we already spent the summer?
So we did.
- Yeah, do you think
that the people that
you're talking about
there that are sort of
the permanent DC class
and the swamp, as
Trump would call them,
do you think it's a conscious
decision that they're
always existing to keep
themselves in that power
or is it just that
you just get there
and then before you know it,
you're just in this thing
and you like what's happening,
so you just stay in that thing.
And so that's why he
was the threat to it.
And I would argue that
in a weird way, you,
now that Trump has stepped away,
a lot of the hatred
that was just
always directed towards Trump
is now directed more towards you
because you're carrying the
torch for some of those ideas.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm not
totally aware of that.
I have a kind of
peripheral sense
that I'm disliked by some
people, but, you know,
I don't have a television,
I don't go on the internet,
I don't use social media.
I'm pretty insulated
from that stuff
because why would
I look in my head?
- You literally don't,
I know you don't check Twitter,
but you literally don't
have a television?
- Oh, no, I've never had it.
I've never had a TV, no.
- Wow.
- No, I just didn't,
I didn't grow up like that and
my dad worked in TV
when I was a kid and
he was pretty pro
reading, I would say,
he was a militant
reading person.
So yeah, we had a lot of
enforced reading in our house,
and so I think
that's how I grew up.
But mostly, you
know, I have a very
close circle of friends
and I have a big family
and I'm really close to my wife
and my producers who
I absolutely love,
my executive producer,
I'm really close to him.
So I have a lot of
people around me
who will tell me
the truth, and do,
if they think I'm being a douche
or I'm crossing some line or
whatever, they'll just say it.
I mean, they're not
afraid of me at all,
so unfortunately.
So I feel like I've
got a pretty good
series of backstops against
going totally crazy.
And then I really care
about their opinion
because these are people
I love and respect.
And so my view has always
been my whole life,
you know, I had a
weird childhood,
which kind of changed
my view on this,
but fundamentally it was,
you should only care
about the opinions
of people who care
about you and who have,
you know, demonstrated
loyalty and wisdom
and an ongoing relationship.
Why would you ever let strangers
have control of your
emotional state?
Like that's insane.
And you know, you
hear people say that,
but I think I'm in the rare
category of people who mean it.
So I would never go online
and like Google myself.
Why would I do that?
What's the upside?
- I Know you mean it.
Right, exactly.
I know you mean it,
'cause I think the first
time we met in person,
I asked you something
about the hate
and the Twitter mentions,
and you're like,
I don't have Twitter.
Like, it's, you know, it's
Tucker Carlson on Twitter,
but like, it's not, you know,
I'm not the one checking it
and tweeting this stuff and
that keeps you kind of
insulated and safe and sane.
- Yeah, and I have a
huge number of people
I talk to every day.
I mean, I spend my whole
life talking to people,
mostly by text,
but hundreds of people.
And I try to clear
my text every night,
it was up until
two in the morning
in front of the fire,
where I live it's cold,
on September 1st
and with my dogs,
you know, and I'm up really late
banging out these
texts, taking notes.
So I speak to a ton of people,
and not just people in my world,
not just famous rich people,
but like a lot of random people.
A waitress that
I had in Big Sur,
I hope she's watching this,
I know she's a fan of yours,
years ago,
I gave her my text
for some reason,
she and her husband are
like such thoughtful people.
And she has been
texting me ever since.
And I swear, once a month,
two nights ago, I used one
of her lines on the air.
Like, at least once a month,
I'll like run with this
story idea she sends me.
So I have a huge number of
people that I correspond with,
but I don't want to
open it up to the mob.
I mean, 'cause then I
can't think clearly.
And my whole job is,
you know, and I don't
always pull it off,
but I really try
to think clearly,
like what is going on here?
You know, ascend a little
bit, get higher, look down,
what are the outlines of this?
And being involved in this,
fuck you, fuck you too.
You know, whoa,
I don't like noise
in my personal life.
I like quiet,
and I don't like noise in my
work or intellectual life.
You know, I like to
think I like nature.
You know, I like like
hunting and fishing,
I like to be outside,
I don't want to sit
in a room and read
other people's hysteria.
I don't think there's any
upside to that at all.
- Trust me, man,
as a guy that just spent
30 days in a rain forest,
basically, I
completely feel that,
and I've realized that
my relationship
with social media
has to be a little
bit different.
And one of the last things
that I remember
before leaving in July
was that you sorta got accosted
while you were going
fishing basically
by some guy.
And what was so
interesting about it,
and I say this about
everything these days,
it's not the incident itself,
it's not the incident,
it's the way the media
reacts to the incident.
So this guy is kind of
getting in your face,
and the way the
whole media was like,
yeah, yeah, well,
Tucker is mean,
so everyone should get in his
face and be more mean about,
and it's like, man,
that will lead us all
to a very dark place.
- Well, someone's
going to get shot.
I mean, I'm serious.
I mean like where do
you think that ends,
you physically confront people
because you don't like their
opinions about politics
in front of their children.
I mean, one of my
kids was there.
I was in a fly shop
that I've gone to for,
you know, many, many years
in a town that I've
gone to for many years
and that I really love.
And it, gosh, it felt,
I mean, this is so whiny
and I try never to whine
in public or private,
but oh wow, it really
felt like a violation,
and I thought, well,
you know, I'm never
going here again,
which was sad,
but then, you know, there are
other places to go, I guess.
I live in a really
beautiful place with just,
I mean, untold miles of
empty rivers and
streams and lakes
and like, why am I
in Montana anyway.
I'll stay in Maine, you know?
But anyway, it just
made me sad and,
but I also think it's
very unwise to do that.
I lived in DC for 35 years.
I would see people all
the time I disagreed with.
You know, I've had
dinner with Nancy Pelosi,
I stood next to Barney Frank,
I remember it at an event,
I could, you know,
that was my whole life.
And the idea of screaming
at someone because
that person disagrees
with you was like insane.
And this is what happens when
you have a secular
society at scale,
which has never happened
in human history.
There's always a religion
because people have
a need for meaning.
You take that away
and people just replace it
with political ideology,
and that's what
it's really about.
The guy screaming at me
felt that I was an apostate.
You know, I was attacking the
one true faith or something.
That's not how I see it,
but it's how a lot
of people do see it,
and I think that
we should be aware
that the end point
of this is violence.
Like, that's where it's going.
You know what I mean?
And I hate that,
I hate violence,
I've seen it a lot, actually,
I'm totally opposed to it.
But the way that the
things have been set up,
the way we communicate,
the end point is violence.
And I just, I say that
all the time on the air,
because I think people
should know that,
let's pull back a little bit.
- Yeah, which is so
interesting because
then the way they'll frame it
is that you're throwing
these firebombs
and it's actually the reverse,
it's a warning.
But to your point on
the secularism part,
do you see where
we're at right now
as just sort of
the end of a purely
sort of secular America, that
at the end of just
a secular America,
two plus two now equals five,
boys or girls, we don't
know which way is up,
our history is no
longer our history.
That sort of without some sort
of undergirding of religion
or some subset of belief
that this is what you get.
And I really fear this
because as you know,
as someone that considered
myself liberal my whole life,
I wanted that thing to work,
but I have come to the
uncomfortable truth
that it cannot work,
it simply cannot work
when it's purely secular.
You know, you're always
gonna have a religion and,
you know, you can say, well,
the crucifixion is kind
of a ridiculous story,
the Talmud is sort
of absurd, okay,
but compared to what.
You know what I mean?
- Right, what do you
got that's better?
- Compared to the idea that
men can get pregnant or two
plus two equals five, like it's,
you know, you're trading one
superstition for another,
and that's just
the state of man.
Like, we're always gonna have
a belief in the transcendent
because we're wired that way,
but you needed to
think carefully about
what god you worship,
you know, what religion
you sign up for here.
And I think we should
be honest about it.
I mean, the political discourse
that I just
described in that you
live in the middle
of every single day
is not about convincing people,
it's not rational
people bringing,
you know, a set of facts
to the conversation
to try to persuade the
other side to join them.
Of course not, it's
a religious war,
that's exactly what it is.
So we should just,
we should name it,
this is a cult, the mask stuff.
You know, I won't
be boring about it,
but in one sentence,
like we spent a year.
First of all,
I was really worried about
COVID at the beginning.
I think we were the
first show on cable TV
to note that COVID
existed 'cause
we're, you know, interested
in the rest of the world,
saw this in central China.
What is this?
I thought, I
believe the numbers,
it's gonna be, you know,
3, 4, 5% mortality, really?
You know, many
millions would die.
So it's not a question of
not taking COVID seriously.
If you take it seriously,
you want solutions
that are effective.
I mean, that's how
you give the virus
the respect it deserves
is by responding
to it rationally.
And the mask stuff
in particularly
things about vaccines
too, but the mask stuff
is so totally unmoored
from any kind of
research data at all.
In fact, there's a lot
of countervailing data
that shows that it's
counterproductive and bad.
We keep saying this
for like a year.
We're like, well, no, there's
this new study out of Vietnam,
the biggest
DataMaster ever done.
And everyone's like, yeah,
shut up, mask denier.
And I finally realized,
'cause I'm not super smart,
but like, you don't care
what the evidence is.
There's no interest whatsoever,
masks are good, this
is what we know,
this is the catechism,
and I'm like, okay, this
isn't public health,
this is theology.
So I don't really know
what you do with theology,
that's why we don't
talk about it.
Like, what, you know,
I'm in Washington,
so when I was a
kid, it was like,
no, you don't talk
about religion
in a public setting because
it's too personal, right?
Sex, religion,
politics, off limits.
So I just don't really
have the tools to argue
with people over religion
because my default setting is,
you know, hey, everyone
has their beliefs,
like, I'm very liberal that way.
The problem is there's as
an evangelical religion.
You know, it's seventh century
Islam, it's convert or die,
it's really, really
aggressive, whoa.
- So what do we do with that?
I mean, I've spent a lot of time
when I was off the grid
thinking about just that,
because I'm with you,
that we sort of are in a
cold civil war in that.
And I don't want a civil war,
obviously, and I
don't want violence
just as you laid out and
I want this thing to work,
but it seems to me you
have a set of people
that I would include
people like us,
in which he's basically
live and let live,
where we can talk about where
the government should be.
But then we have this other
set that want everything,
and they want everything from us
and to tell us how
to do everything.
That's not a liberal
arguing with a conservative,
that's something
much more dangerous,
because they are
not going to stop.
So what do we do with that,
those of us that
wanna live freely?
- You know, I don't know.
I've been, like you,
I haven't been in a tree
house for a month, I wish,
but I have been
brooding about it.
And you know, my instinct is,
I think is the same
as everyone else's.
You know, let's use
the federal system
to, you know, create
zones of choice
where people can decide
how they wanna live,
you know, by moving there.
You know, certain states
will have these rules,
others will have
another set of rules
commensurate with the desires
of the people they represent,
like, that's (indistinct).
- But will that be enough
as they're always trying
to give the federal
government more power
and the presidency when
it's their guy, more power.
- So that's kind of the problem.
It's like, that's not
their temperament at all.
So you know, I live
in a super rural area
where it's basically
1985 and people just
they don't spend a single second
worrying about the sex lives
of hipsters in Brooklyn,
like, it's not even a thing.
It's like, they're
interested in Brooklyn,
they'll go and check it out,
but they're not.
- Their sex lives
aren't that great
from what I understand.
- Well, I know, they're all
in voluntarily celibate.
That's (indistinct)
isn't my obsession.
No one's having sex.
Everyone's talking about
sex, no one's doing it,
which is like so
distressing to me.
But anyway, whole separate
talk, but here's my point,
in Brooklyn,
there are people
laying awake at night,
really agitated on
a sincere level too,
it's not just performative,
worried that there are people
in my zip code who are like,
maintaining these attitudes
that are unacceptable
and must be stamped out.
So it's like, it's asymmetrical.
Like, one side is evangelical,
wants to convert the
other side or kill them,
and the other side is just like,
kind of traditionally liberal.
Like, Hey, you do your
thing, I'll do mine,
that's why I live here.
You know, we don't have a
police department in my town,
obviously, and
that's because no
one can afford it,
of course, but also no dentist,
'cause no one can afford it,
but it's also because
unless you're doing
something really outrageous,
like, there's no
need for the police.
Like, the, I will say this,
I live in a state that
votes kind of mixed,
it's probably mostly
Democrat actually,
but because it's sparsely
populated and huge,
that there really
is this tolerance
that I've never
seen anywhere else.
Like, they put up
in a small town,
and anyone who lives
in a small town can,
I think confirmed
this, 'cause it's just,
it's true everywhere.
They put up with
levels of eccentricity
of like truly weird behavior
in a way that like liberals
used to dream about.
I mean, there are people
in my town doing like
totally weird things,
and people still
see them as people,
they're not reduced
to their weirdest
perversion or something.
It's like, no,
he's a good father,
but he also exposes himself
when the train goes by.
Like, you know what I mean?
And actually
there literally was a person
like that in my town for real.
And everyone loved him.
- They can probably do
something about a guy like that,
but I get the broader point.
- No, but you see what
I'm saying, it's like,
but people here were so,
that you see whole person.
And I feel like
in internet world,
it's like, oh, you said
something mean about gays
15 years ago or you
were insensitive
to black people by
current standards then.
Like, it's done, it's over,
like no more job for you.
And I'm not defending
being mean to any group,
of course not, I'm just saying
that people are super
complicated and they have
good days and bad days and
virtuous qualities and
very ugly qualities,
and they're all mixed
together in people,
like that's who we are.
But that's not
acknowledged online,
because people's
statements are totally
dis-aggregated from the person,
and that's not true
in a small town,
you have to deal with people.
Like, we only have one
store, it's a gas station,
everyone uses it every day.
So you see people every day.
So there are people
in there probably
vote for candidates I
hate or doing weird shit,
you know, when the
lights are off,
but I still know who they are,
you know what I mean?
Like I said, those people.
- There's three
dimensions there.
That's actually a perfect
segue, and of course,
I do wanna talk
about the book too,
so I promise you
we'll get there.
But that's actually
a perfect segue
to some of the tech stuff.
Because I think the first
time I was on your show,
which is a couple
of years ago now,
and we did it this
way, not in person,
but online,
I was taking the more
libertarian approach
on the big tech stuff.
I was basically like,
and this is probably
three years ago
and things have
now been exposed,
which is why I've
changed my opinion a bit,
but I was basically like
they're private companies,
let them do their thing,
we'll build better
things and all that.
Now, you know, I'm
building stuff.
But at this point
it seems to me,
and your argument, I think
was a little more like,
oh, well there are
antitrust things,
there's something
government's got to do.
I don't know exactly
what, but something.
I've really come around to that.
Because to me at this point,
if we don't do anything,
then we're all anarchists.
It's like, if the
government doesn't exist
to do something about how
they're manipulating us,
then what is the
purpose at any level?
Do you feel like you've
been pretty right on it
the entire time,
and where are you
now at this point?
Because I know you don't
love the administration.
It's like you want
them to have the power
to break up these companies?
- Well, I haven't been right
about anything the whole time.
I mean, my views are
constantly in flux.
My views are utterly
different and, you know,
I have the misfortune of having
been on camera for 25 years.
So like, it's
pretty easy to prove
that my views today
are not what they were,
they're not even close.
And I'm not ashamed of
that in the slightest,
I think people who pay
attention changed their minds
when the evidence changes.
Our conclusions always
ought to be evidence-based.
And so, I mean, I
was a libertarian.
I mean, I was a fellow at
the Cato Institute, unpaid,
it's hard to even believe that,
but you know, it's a different
country, and I, anyway,
so my view currently is that
democracy is
incompatible with this
level of concentrated power
in the hands of a few people.
So the promise of democracy
is that everybody has power
by virtue of their citizenship,
we all have a hand in
choosing our rulers.
And that's what keeps
the society calm because,
you know, you don't have
to storm the best deal or
hurt anybody because you know,
in two years or four
years or six years,
you have a chance,
a meaningful chance,
if you get your neighbors
involved, to make a change.
If people start to
understand or believe that
they don't have that
power, they go crazy.
You know, they become
really, really radical,
that abets radicalism.
And the tech power
is so overwhelming.
I mean, all
information in English
flows through one
portal, Google,
that, I mean, Google literally,
and I'm not saying this
as a partisan at all,
just like as somebody
cares about democracy
prevented the Trump campaign
from raising money
with its Gmail lists
in the last week
of the campaign.
I don't think that
was ever reported,
the Trump campaign
was so stupid,
they never said
anything about it.
But someone told me and
I verified, that's true.
So like, you don't
have to believe,
you know, nut cake Sidney Powell
to think, you know,
that the voting machines
were rigged or whatever,
that right there is rigging,
that's not a free
and fair election
if one side can't
raise money, what?
Like, that's never
happened before.
And I'm not even getting
into the, you know,
the rejiggering
of search results,
which are clearly designed to
produce propaganda rather than
what they promise,
which is to produce the
most popular results,
no, it, the whole thing.
- Tucker, they've got a word,
they made up a word
for it, it's unbiasing.
That's what they do, they
unbiased when they rejigger.
- It's the whole
thing, it's like,
it's so beyond and it's,
I mean, first of all,
it's driving people crazy,
it's making people into like
for real conspiracy knots,
because there actually are
conspiracies that we can prove
for the first time in my
lifetime, 52 years, A,
B, it's making people
radical because
it has destroyed their
belief in the system,
and C, it is totally
incompatible with
the system itself.
In our system, the government
has to be the most powerful
entity in the country, why?
Because it's
accountable to voters.
So ultimately people
who were born here,
who are citizens
of this country,
are supposed to be able to
control it on the big questions.
If all of those
decisions are made,
you know, Google
is more powerful
than the federal
government, which it is,
and Google is not
an American company,
it's owned by shareholders
from around the world,
a sovereign wealth fund of
Malaysia or whatever or China,
then, like, who's in
charge of the country?
I mean, it raises like really
deep questions like that.
So no, for our own survival,
we have to break it up.
And Teddy Roosevelt,
you know, who really was always
been my favorite president,
when I was a kid I loved
Teddy Roosevelt because
he was such an
extraordinary person.
He actually hurt
members of my family.
You know, with (indistinct).
- Wait, what do you mean?
Well, my mother's family was,
had, you know, owned
the Sugar Trust,
and so he broke that up,
you know, it was a
monopoly on sugar,
and the half of Myers, and
he broke it up and, you know,
even when I was a kid,
you know, my
great-grandmother was like,
well, who was from their family,
was like, Teddy Roosevelt, bad,
but I always thought
he was a cool guy.
And so I liked him
for those reasons.
Now, as I age, I realized
what a wise man he was.
He was just an
extraordinary person.
He believed in capitalism,
he believed in democracy,
he was actually
deeply conservative,
he didn't want radical change.
There was massive
global technological
change on his watch.
It was called the
industrial revolution,
and it reached its kind of apex
around 1,990 to 1901
when he became president,
and it unleashed all kinds of
like super volatile politics.
And in fact, it culminated
in the Bolshevik Revolution,
October, 1917, which enslaved
half the world for 50 years.
So like these technological
changes have affects that,
you know, are
really, really deep,
and Roosevelt could see this.
It was anarchism, not
communism at the time,
but the anarchist movement
was killing people like
all over the country.
In Chicago, Denver,
you know, Butte,
Montana, New York City,
and Teddy Roosevelt's
like, whoa, whoa, whoa,
we need to return
some of this power,
this political power to voters
or else the country, the
systems will collapse
and we're gonna get some
kind of dictatorship,
and he was totally right.
And so the trust busting that
he engaged in was in fact,
you know, a last
ditch effort to save
the systems that he believed in,
capitalism and democracy.
So, you know, clearly,
you know, that's what
Trump's should have done.
You know, he wasn't
serious enough
to do that, unfortunately
and there were a lot
of other problems,
but I don't think he could see,
I don't think Trump
fully understood this
or I, you know, I don't know.
I'll let historians
figure it out, but
we kind of missed a chance
to make these reforms,
and I'm definitely
worried about it.
Definitely worried about it.
- That's the messed up part.
'Cause it's like, I'm with
you and then it's like, oh,
do you wanna give the
Biden administration
the chance to do this as if
they won't make it worse.
By the way, I'm guessing you
covered this on your show,
but you know they took
Teddy Roosevelt statue down
at the museum of natural
history in New York City
because of something he
said about Native Americans,
and it's like,
the planet that
these people live on,
I don't live on that
planet, I don't think.
- Well, I mean, Teddy,
I mean, whatever I
can't even get into,
I actually have a signed,
in my barn a signed picture
from Teddy Roosevelt,
it's my great-grandfather,
over my sink.
I really (indistinct), but look,
they don't know anything
is the bottom line.
Teddy Roosevelt
lived with Indians,
Teddy Roosevelt knew more
about American Indians
than any president in history,
he literally lived with them.
No, he wasn't a
hater of America,
these people never met
an American Indian.
I mean the whole thing
is their children.
And the thing about children,
I've got a ton of them,
I can tell you, I was one once,
is they have this
moral certainty
that's completely
uninformed by experience,
they don't know how up they are,
personally because
they never failed.
So it was very easy for a
trial to make swift and severe
moral judgments about others
in the way that when you're 52,
it's like a little
harder to judge
'cause you know how
screwed up you are, right?
So this is why the Khmer Rouge
had 15 year old soldiers.
And that's the species
of what we're seeing,
take down Teddy Roosevelt,
he's white, okay.
Teddy Roosevelt was like
in a meaningful way,
the most progressive president,
like, in the 100 year
span in which he, yeah,
it's so stupid, I
can't deal with it.
- All right, we'll
move on from that.
One more thing
and then the book.
So I just wanna talk about the
media landscape in general,
because one of the things
that I'm realizing now
that I'm back on the grid is
I spend so much of
the time on my show,
just cleaning up lies,
just AOC said, this it's a lie,
CNN said this it's a lie,
Kavanaugh, everything
they said was a lie,
Covington kids,
all the stuff that you've
covered, obviously.
And I'm just a little curious,
first off, like how
bad you think really
like the CNN MSNBC, New
York Times, WaPo machine is.
On one hand, but
on the other hand,
just like a little insider
stuff on how you guys go about
doing your show
on a daily basis.
'Cause I know your
producers a little bit,
and obviously I go on the show,
and I find that you do the
show in a way where it's like,
you're almost doing like a,
it almost feels more like
a book than a TV show,
where it's like each day
you're doing something
and then you sort of
pick up the next day
and pick up the next day,
and I'm trying to do
something similar here,
so that everything doesn't feel
like this disconnected
lunacy that everyone else,
and I'm just wondering
a little bit about
like the nuts and bolts
about how you guys
decide to do what
you're gonna do.
- Well, I'm a writer,
so that's how I think, you know,
in terms of chapters
and, you know, serials,
this is, you know,
giving you one installment
today, another tomorrow,
it's just how my brain works.
But as a practical matter,
you know, I wake up,
not too early, I hope.
And with my wife and four dogs,
I try and sit outside for a
minute, get my head together,
and then I write out
a memo every morning
for the whole staff
on what I think the lead ought
to be, who we should book,
and we've got a whole pipe,
we have some unbelievable
people who work on the show,
just really, really smart,
I mean, really smart.
And one of the people
I talked to a lot,
so you know, we've
had, if I can brag,
the same staff for five years,
I think we've lost one
person, two people,
and it's pretty big staff.
And they're just,
they're all in,
they're so clever,
they're so creative,
they're so interesting.
But one of our head tape
guys, a guy called Tom Fox,
guy is just a freaking genius.
And he really is my
window into cable news.
Like, the the poor
guy is very smart,
but he watches those cable news.
So he's constantly
texting me (indistinct)
- He drinks a lot, I'm guessing.
- What?
- It seems pretty sober, but
I mean, maybe he's on pills,
I don't know.
But I like, you know,
I sit there with my,
you know, stupid
glasses on my phone
and I'm looking at him, I'm
like, I honestly can't believe,
I cannot believe
they would say this.
So basically by like
11:30 in the morning,
you know, I've sketched out
what I think the show should be,
in my mind, it's always
had, because again,
I was a reporter and
a magazine writer,
I think in terms of the lead,
you know, what's my editor used
to say to me when I was kid,
get in the lead.
And I'm like, but
what's the lead,
like how do you open it up?
You know, what's the theme?
And I try to,
as an exercise that I've always,
you know, that I learned as
a kid and I've always used,
sum it up in a sentence,
you know, what's it about?
You know, our first segment
usually goes 20, 25 minutes,
what's it about?
One sentence.
It's not about eight things,
it's about one thing.
How would you summarize it?
And that's a really helpful
organizing principle
for putting it
together, and then,
you know, right
around five o'clock,
I try and take a
sauna every day,
'cause I think it's really
important, a Scandinavian,
I'm true to my people.
And I think about it in
the sauna, then I go out
and I think about it more,
and then I sit down around 5:00,
have a cup of coffee and
I start writing the lead.
And so that's basically it,
but the media stuff is so
shocking to me because I,
you know, I worked
at CNN for years,
and I was to the couple shows
there or several shows there,
and then I,
you know, I was the main
anchor on MSNBC for four years,
I got fired,
but you know, I still
have a really good friend
who remain nameless,
who works there,
just a wonderful
person, really good guy,
and I have a couple
of friends at CNN,
so not a ton, two,
but anyway, but I know that
world really, really well.
And the biggest surprise
for me in one sentence
is how illiberal they are.
I always imagined
their liberal networks.
No, no, no, I'm liberal, okay?
In the sense that like,
I believe in the
enlightenment and
I believe in the bill of rights
and I think we do have rights.
They are not liberals,
they are defenders
of the powerful,
which is that much graver sin.
Like, you can have silly
politics, I get it,
I've had silly politics,
maybe I do now,
people make mistakes,
but defending the
billionaire class,
blaming everything on like
working class white people
who are like, you know,
by far the most shafted
people in America,
look at the suicide rate,
look at the death rate.
I mean, it's like,
it's measurable.
But everything's their fault.
It's insane.
CNN ran a piece today saying
white supremacists are
applauding the Taliban,
and it's like, okay,
you know, I don't even know
what they're talking about,
but leaving that
aside, it's like,
what are you really saying?
You're saying
the real problem with
withdrawal from Afghanistan
was not terrible decisions that
the Biden ministration
made and the Pentagon made
or that our entire foreign
policy establishment,
bi-partisan made for 20 years.
Now, the real problem
is some guy in Alabama
who's got unauthorized views.
It's like, maybe you should
stop attacking these people
because they are the weakest
people in our society,
and you're doing it
in order to defend,
like the shitiest
people in our society
but also the richest
and the most powerful,
you're the Praetorian guard
for the most powerful people.
Like, how can you
live with yourself?
I mean that,
that is so immoral.
- So what do you think the
answer to that question is?
How do they,
when you have to cover
some idiotic thing
that Stelter said or Cuomo,
just these clown people, when
you have to cover it, right?
Or Don Lumon as you call them,
like, how do you think
they live with themselves
at this point when they
just lie again and again,
and we have the internet
to expose the lies.
This isn't 20 years ago
when you were on CNN,
and we couldn't expose things,
we can expose it now
and they still do it.
- Well, it's, I guess I
would ask myself, like,
I mean, I lie if I'm really
cornered or something, I lie.
I really try not to.
I try never to lie on TV.
I just don't, you know,
I don't like lying.
I certainly do it, you know,
out of weakness or whatever,
but to systematically
lie like that
without asking yourself,
like, why am I doing this?
So if these people ask them,
just why am I doing this?
They'll say well,
because I wanna protect
the system, because I really
believe in the system.
Okay, who's running the system?
You're aligned to
defend Jeff Bezos.
Like, you're treating Bill Gates
like some sort of moral
leader, like, are you kidding?
Like, how dare you do that?
How dare you use your power
to protect and guard the
powerful even as you,
you know, put your boot on the
neck of the weakest people,
some Catholic school kid from
Kentucky, it's like a parody.
Are you kidding?
The kid's a child,
and you're using your
power to crush him,
to wreck his life,
like, that shocks me.
And I have to say,
there've been many times
in the 25 years I've
been in TV where I think,
you know, are we using this,
like, very substantial
power that we have,
to put pictures on the
screen to hurt weak people?
And I have done that
inadvertently over the years
because I got carried away,
but I really try not to.
And everyone who works
on our show is very aware
of like the most basic rule,
which is don't piss down,
don't attack people beneath you.
If you're gonna, you
know, take a punch,
make sure it's upward.
Someone who's richer,
stronger, more powerful,
in charge of more things
than you were, punch up.
Like, that's just
like a life rule.
And people who punched
down are the worst,
they should have no power
whatsoever, in my opinion.
- Right.
And the irony is
they're punching down
while pretending they're
doing the opposite,
which is the grossest part.
All right, wait, let's
talk about the book,
'cause I thought it
was really interesting.
So the book is basically
a collection of essays
that you've written
over a couple decades
over about 30 years.
And there's a line
right in the front
that I thought was
great actually.
You say magazine journalism
is worth remembering.
And that you also then
go on to say that,
you know, some of the stuff
in these pages you got right,
some of the stuff you got wrong,
some of it could have
been written today
and would be as
important, some of it not,
but magazine journalism
is worth remembering.
I thought that was
a key line there,
because it seems
really dead right now.
Like, when I read
any of the things
that 10 years ago
were respectable,
The Atlantic, just
any of the things,
like they're just
all terrible now.
Was there a moment
that it shifted?
Was it as pure as maybe
we all thought it will be,
was at one point
or, or any of that?
- Well, the funny thing is this,
I grew up thinking it
was kind of shallow.
My father was (indistinct).
- Oh, God, were
really in trouble now.
- I know.
So my father was a
magazine writer, actually,
when I was born
and a successful one.
And I remember him saying to
me in this sort of acid way
about a relative of ours who
was smart, and he said, oh,
that person is smart.
And my father goes, clever,
she reads magazines.
I'll never forget that,
She reads magazines.
- The lowest of the low.
Right, rather than books.
Like smart people,
deep people read books.
Because as my father
always told us,
there is value in the
process of reading a book,
you have to follow a
narrative for 300 pages.
You have to pay attention
to the same storyline
as it unfolds and develops,
and that's really good
training for your brain,
'cause you see things
longitudinally.
And you understand
that sometimes
the consequences of decisions
aren't apparent for a very
long time, like that's,
you know, long stories are good.
But you know, I was a magazine
writer and a book author,
but really a magazine writer.
And now that doesn't
exist really,
and the reason it doesn't exist
is because people can't read
for 30 minutes at a time,
because their brains
have been so totally
changed by the iPhone
that they don't even have
the ability to do it.
It's so amazing to me.
So that's part of
what's going on
is the process of staring
at this tiny screen for
half your day or more
has changed the way you
metabolize information.
And I remember when
Twitter first came out,
I made fun of it to
everybody I knew,
like 140 or whoever
number characters, like,
that's the space with which
we have to express our
the deepest truths in
American society, like,
we're kind of, actually.
If that's, you know,
'cause the medium
really matters.
And now it's like
totally normal.
You know, the
president United States
was communicating his
thoughts on Twitter and now,
you know, that's the forum.
And so it's the medium itself,
it's not simply that the
business model went away,
and that's all true, of course,
it was taken over by the
worst people, yeah, obviously.
But it was that the
American population
became incapable of
consuming this media
because it was too long.
Oh, that's so awful
if you think about it.
- No, listen as a guy that just
took a month off the phone,
I get it.
I'm more patient now.
Even when I opened
up Twitter again,
on a quick scroll, I was like,
these people are all insane.
Even though it had nothing
to do whether I agreed
or disagreed, it was just like
this short burst thought war
is just making us all crazy.
- I know.
And you know, that the other
thing is it's all transmit,
that's the problem with it.
And for me, that's the
thing that I miss most,
especially now that
I'm a talk show host,
and I don't do
any real reporting
of the kind that I used to do,
is that all I do is talk,
all I do is express my views.
And that imperils
your soul after
a pretty short period of time.
Like, it's not good for you.
And if you know,
any talk show hosts,
like they're unbearable.
You know, I can think of
a couple in particular,
- I'm trying, man.
you just cannot talk to them,
because they don't
listen, they only talk,
they're only on
transmit, no receive.
And the beauty of writing
magazine stories was
part of the deal, in fact,
the essence of the deal
was going out and listening
to people shutting up,
blending in, watching,
taking in other
people's experiences
and then thinking about them.
And you have to have
that in your life
or else you'd just become,
and men as they age,
by the way, become
less capable of listening
and more insistent on
talking all the time.
And I'm already that way anyway.
I mean, I just, I can't shut up.
So for me, it's really, the
job is really dangerous.
Like, I could wind up,
and I've told my wife,
I keep a 38 next to my bed,
my whole life I was
a little, you know,
two inch barrel,
special and I was like,
just take it headshot,
end it, if I become
like a lot of these people
we both know in our business,
just end it before I humiliate
myself in front of the kids,
before they don't wanna,
you know, be around me anymore
'cause I can't shut up
and listen, you know?
So that's, I do miss that,
I really, really miss that,
just going out and listening.
- So you also lead in the book,
you talk a little bit about
how the business has changed,
'cause it's not just
our brains have changed.
So that's changed, you know,
sort of long form journalism,
but also the way the structures
themselves has changed.
And you juxtapose the way
the publishing world
treated Josh Hawley's book
versus Hunter Biden's book.
And I think it's
a perfect example
of almost everything that's
wrong with things right now.
- Yeah, it was so
distressing for me.
I mean, the book is published
by Simon & Schuster,
it's the second book in a
row I've written for them,
the last I would
ever write for them.
I mean, it's such a
disgusting company
run by disgusting people,
but I didn't fully appreciate
that I knew that,
I knew that the guy who runs
it, this guy, John Karp was
dishonest and not super smart.
But you know, that goes for
a lot of people in our world.
In January...
- How do you really feel,
Tucker, come on, open up.
- Oh, he's awful,
He's absolutely awful.
But I know, you know, whatever,
you deal with awful people,
I mean, you know, I can
be awful, so I get it.
I'm not that judgy
in my personal life,
but in January, right after,
you know, January 7th,
Simon Schuster issues
a statement saying
we're canceling Josh
Hawley's book because
he is an insurrectionist.
So I was like, hmm, Josh Hawley
seems kind of mild-mannered,
so I looked into it,
and he basically, he
voted to, you know,
stop the certification,
the vote,
let's figure out the
vote was fair, whatever.
Okay, and you can
agree or disagree,
I wasn't calling for
anyone to do that.
In point of fact,
just so you know,
like, I'm not even
sure I was bothered,
but he did it.
Democrats did the same thing
after the 2016 election,
after 2004, like I watched
it, like, I know this.
So I'm like, what made
Josh Hawley special?
Nothing really,
Democrats were mad at Josh
Hawley so Simon & Schuster
canceled his book,
which had nothing to
do with what's on it,
it was on big tech actually.
So I was like shocked by this.
You know, publishers have
to be for free speech,
they have to,
that's a prerequisite.
They're the gatekeepers of our
corporate intellectual life
or common intellectual life,
and so they have to
allow for a dialogue,
a free exchange of ideas.
And maybe on the
way out margins,
maybe they're not, you know,
reprinting Mein Kampf
every year, get it,
but like the strike zone has
to be really, really wide,
it really does,
and it always has been.
And so I was like, I was
really shocked by this.
So I was rabbit
hunting in Maine.
It was like a blizzard,
and I'll never forget it
was in my truck driving,
and I got so pissed, I called
John Karp and he answered.
And I was like, did you just
cancel this book because
you don't like his vote?
And he's like, well, I
said, you're disgusting,
what you did is totally
disgusting and wrong and
I feel implicated in it
because I owe you this book.
And I don't wanna
write a book for you,
but I'm under contract to do it
and you're holding
me to the contract,
I just wanna get out of it.
Oh no, you must write the book.
I said, well, if I'm
gonna write the book,
I'm gonna open it with
the story of what you did.
And I want to interview
you and that the idiot,
you know, the editor.
And so I did, I interviewed
them on Zoom for an hour
and I took notes and I
printed the conversation
and the intro to this book,
and they come off is every
bit as shallow and dumb,
and like completely unprincipled
as you would expect in
your worst nightmare
of what New York
publishing is like.
Like, I was really
shocked by it.
And it was just sad.
And so at that point,
it kind of put them
in a tough situation.
They don't wanna print
attacks on them, of course,
but they figured correctly
that if they cancel a book
about how they've canceled
other people's books,
probably a PR nightmare,
so they had to go
through with it.
You know, they hate me more
than they've ever hated anybody,
but obviously I don't care.
But I just felt a
moral obligation.
Because they were sending
me money to do this book
and I didn't want to
be part of it at all,
and I really did my best to
get out of doing this book.
They threatened to sue me,
they really got up
in my face about it.
And so I was like, okay, fine,
I'm gonna write a book
about you, and I did.
And I dedicated it to John
Karp and what a worm he is,
and I really mean that.
- So you juxtapose that
with the Hunter stuff,
and the Hunter stuff was a
little bit different, right?
The publishing world and
big tech and everybody,
a little bit different
when it came to Hunter.
- Hunter Biden's illiterate.
Like, I know a hundred
Biden really well.
He was my neighbor.
- Right, you talk
about that, yeah.
- Yeah, and I always, I
mean, I always liked him and,
you know, I used to
party way too much,
and I quit 19 years ago.
So I'm the last person who's
going to judge an addiction.
- I still use nicotine
product, you know,
every waking hour.
So you're not gonna
catch me being like,
oh, you're addicted,
you know, I get it.
And there are a lot of
things about Hunter I like
and always did like and
I feel so bad for him,
anyway, it's a very
complicated story,
but I'm not anti Hunter Biden.
But pretending that Hunter
Biden can like write a book
or has something useful to say,
or even as an audience
is like insulting to me.
I know the answers to all
those questions are no.
So they paid him
millions of dollars.
What are they doing?
They're paying off
the administration.
Of course, because they
see the federal government
as their real audience.
They don't mind
that they lost all the money
on the Hunter Biden book,
they made a statement
that the people in charge,
you know, are on the
same team as they are.
And I think that's so
dark, it's unbelievable.
And just to be totally clear,
there are a lot of
payoffs in American life.
The society is
increasingly corrupt,
and of all the people
who get pay offs,
Hunter Biden is not
the worst person.
I know, I probably,
everyone's will be like,
really you're defending
a Hunter Biden.
You know, there are
a lot of bad people,
and Hunter Biden is
not a bad person,
he's just screwed up,
you know, whatever,
done a lot of bad things.
But so I wasn't mad that
they gave him the money,
I'm just mad that they paid
off a political regime.
Like, that is not your
job if you're a publisher,
you're supposed to be brave.
- By the way.
I mean, the publishing
world was also giving what?
5 million to now
disgraced former,
I didn't know until yesterday,
former New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo for a book
in the middle of the pandemic.
- You missed all that?
- I missed all that.
It was a good month, man,
it was a good month.
- You know, it's so funny is,
I mean, you've been doing
this for a long time.
August was always,
like, I haven't taken a
single day off in August,
and that was always the
time where, you know,
I would always go on a
fishing trip or whatever,
you know, go to
Europe or Deuce 'cause
it's August, nothing happens.
It's not the hallway month,
- That was why I did it.
we make up stories.
But all of a sudden it's like,
you go away for August
and you missed a ton.
- Yeah, well, actually
speaking of that,
let's just do one more
August related thing, man
and then we'll get
back to the book.
The Afghanistan stuff,
obviously, I have to ask
you a little bit about that,
'cause I'm just
catching up on it
literally in the last 24 hours.
It's sort of, from
my perspective,
impossible to tell
exactly what happened
from a media perspective,
because it seems like
they really are trying
to figure out a way not to
blame the administration,
but this thing seems
like as bad of bungling as,
could it have been
worse at this point?
Like, what could
have made this worse,
this exit and now,
everything that's happening/
- I can't see it.
And I say that as
someone who was
passionately in favor
of withdrawing troops,
because I didn't see the point,
no one could ever explain
what the mission was,
and that's just a violation
of my most basic rule of life,
which is know why
you're doing something.
You know what I mean?
Especially when people are dying
and you're spending trillions
to do it, what is it?
And no one could answer it.
So I was totally for
pulling out, but to,
in order of severity,
leave American citizens behind,
move tens of thousands
of unvetted Afghans
who did not work
for the US military,
who weren't our allies,
whose identities we don't
know into suburban America,
and then three, to
leave behind $90 billion
worth of military equipment
and an entire air force,
360,000 automatic battle rifles,
heavy machine guns,
Black Hawks, Fixed Wing,
I mean, it's,
the Taliban now control
the best armed military
of its size in the world.
- It's unimaginable, true.
- It's unbelievable.
And then you start learning,
and I felt I was pretty
well versed on Afghan.
I mean, I first went over there
in October of 2001 because
I was a working journalist
and, you know, it was my job.
So I've sorta paid attention
to Afghanistan for 20 years,
not as deeply as
I thought I was,
however, because we
learn all these things,
it was like, was that
really happening?
The president of Afghanistan
left the country
without telling anyone.
Some of his aides
who were at lunch
got back to the office
and he was gone.
He was on a flight to Kyrgyzstan
with tens of millions
of US currency.
Well, how did that happen?
Who was this guy?
Turns out, we installed as
the president of Afghanistan,
a professor from Johns Hopkins
who like is the last person.
I mean, it just tells
you everything about
our ruling class, which
is they only talk to
believe, trust, promote
people exactly like them.
If you are,
I don't think you speak Dari
or Pashto, I'm assuming,
but if I said Dave Ruben,
your job is to pick a
leader of Afghanistan,
you'd probably pick some pretty
tough posh tune warlord type
who could make
the provinces obey
if you wanted to central
government, right?
- He probably wouldn't
have gone to John Hopkins,
how about that?
- So then it turns
out that this guy's,
he's got two kids, both
with American passports.
One is a and I'm quoting,
visual artist in Brooklyn,
and the other was a staff
for Pete Buttigieg's
presidential campaign.
And you're like, wait a second,
Afghanistan, the poorest
country in the world
but the other side,
you know, south Asia,
other side of the globe,
we pick a leader who is
exactly like our leaders.
And that's how you know, that
it's all about narcissism.
Like, it's only about
self-love, self-worship.
Like, these people
are incompetent
because they're narcissists.
Like, they can't
imagine that anybody,
but a Johns Hopkins
professor of some like,
totally douchey discipline too,
like, social science.
He's not even like
a math professor,
he's not like even
a real professor.
And they made him
president of Afghanistan
because we though he was...
- I think it was
lesbian dance theory,
I'll have to check
that, but I think, yeah.
But how bad do you, I mean,
like, how bad do you
think this will be?
I mean, it seems to me, this
is almost the type of thing
if we had an honest media
that could actually
topple administration.
Like, this seems like,
and now the phone call
where Biden basically was
in advance trying to
cover the whole thing up
about how bad things
had gotten there.
Like, this seems
extraordinarily awful.
- Yeah, I mean, I think
it's one of those moments,
and there aren't, you know,
usually things
change incrementally
in a way that's only
barely perceptible
and you wake up and
everything's different.
You know, 2015 in
the middle-class
became the minority of
the American population,
no one really noticed,
six years later, it's
like pretty obvious, okay?
That we live in Brazil.
This is one of
those rare moments
where the pivot point is
like, right in your face,
it's crisp, it's dramatic,
it's on television.
Like, you know that nothing
will be the same after this,
you're just not exactly sure
in what way it
will be different,
but the obvious, the
obvious effects of course,
will just a radical
diminishment of American power.
You know, it's pretty clear the
United States can't actually
enforce its will even on
the stone age country,
it can't make anybody do
what it wants them to do,
it won't protect people
it says it will protect,
it can't even protect
its own citizens
'cause it doesn't even try.
The people in charge are dumb,
they don't know they're dumb,
they have no actual skills,
they're totally unaware of that.
Like it's just, it's
rip the mask off.
And I'm not personally
smart enough to figure out
all the ramifications of this,
but they are
absolutely profound.
And you're going to
see an acceleration
of trends already in progress,
which is like none of the 340
million people who live here
really think the
people in charge
have any clue what
they're doing,
nobody really believes
the system is real,
nobody actually thinks
we live in a
representative democracy,
nobody really believes
in American empire.
Like, it just makes
everybody totally cynical,
totally atomized,
there is no kind of center
of gravity in America.
Like, right, this is bad, man,
I think it's really, really bad.
- Is that the most dangerous
place that a country can be,
that it only works if we
believe that it works?
And we sort of,
it feels like we're
in the show must go on
version of democracy.
Like, oh, it's
just got to go on,
'cause it's got to go on
even though the president
probably has dementia,
nobody's listening to anybody,
we're we're unearthing
and upending everything
we ever believed in,
but we got to keep
the show going.
- But everything works that way.
I mean, there's a huge
corpus of literature on,
you know, the effective
attitude on health.
You know, there are cases,
not a few, many cases,
that are documented in
the medical literature
of people who got better
'cause they like decided to.
So like, you know, mind over
matter, that's a real thing.
How you feel about something,
and the opposite is also true.
Anxiety can give you cancer,
well, like terminal cancer.
So how you feel about something
determines what that thing is.
And in the case of like a huge,
incredibly complex project like
running a country this big,
it's determinative, it
makes all the difference.
Like, if people believe
in it, it works,
if they don't, it doesn't.
And I'm just amazed,
there are a lot of reasons
why no one believes
in the system anymore,
but I'm just amazed
by the recklessness
of a ruling class that
sets out intentionally
to destroy, say patriotism.
And then what do
you replace it with?
We haven't replaced
it with anything.
So like we kneel for the Anthem.
Okay, what's your idea?
You know, we don't
have a racial majority,
a religious majority,
increasingly not even a
meaningful linguistic majority.
Like, what is it that
holds the country together?
What do we all have
in common, you know?
Countries don't hang
together by accident.
You know, centrifugal forces
is a physics principle,
like, it breaks apart
unless there's a reason for
it to hold together, period.
So what's ours?
And the idea that they would
systematically go through
and like, destroy
the last remaining
connective tissue between
hundreds of millions of
Americans, professional sports,
well, we're all into
football, not anymore anymore.
That's a political category now.
You know, we all believe in
the military, not anymore.
They're lecturing
us about white rage.
Oh, shit I'm white,
I guess I'm excluded from this.
I mean like, well,
who thought of this?
This is the single
craziest thing
our ruling class has
done, has been thematic,
and the theme is destroy the
connection between Americans.
- It's so interesting,
you're saying that.
Because since I just caught
up on the Afghanistan thing,
as I'm trying to
piece it all together
in a short amount of time,
it feels to be almost like
it's intentionally horrible.
It's like, if you were
intentionally trying
to not only destroy Afghanistan,
but to destroy our credibility,
make us look like fools,
make it look like
no one's in charge.
Could you do it any
better than he did?
- No, you couldn't.
It actually just,
it breaks my heart and
you know, I don't
know the answer.
I've asked a lot of really
smart people who know,
you know, much rote about how
the military works than I do,
and some of them have
recently been in Afghanistan.
I probably asked five
or six people like that,
everyone I know like
that in the last week.
This looks intentional to me,
this looks like vandalism,
this doesn't look
like an accident.
And all of them have said,
you know, I'm not sure,
but I think they
really are that dumb.
- Gosh, that's even scarier.
- Well, it is scarier.
But you also think like,
motive may not even matter
as much as the fact.
I mean, the message, of
course, to China, and
I mean, everybody I
know had the same,
I wish you had
been, you were in,
you know, in your tree house
when this happened, but
the moment that cobble fell,
I must've gotten five texts
from smart people like, no,
with the exact same
reaction, which is man,
if I lived in Taipei,
I'd be off showing
my money right now
and buying a condo
in Santa Monica.
Like, everybody had
the same reaction.
Taiwan is just screwed,
and I think that's true.
But that's just a small
piece of the effect of this.
I mean, rarely do empires,
short of like full
defeat in a war
and as a broccoli,
as ours just did,
like we're done.
So what does that mean for us?
I mean, in some ways,
I never thought we were
served by the American empire,
especially, I don't know
how much we've gotten
out of Puerto Rico and
Guam and Afghanistan
and all these other colonies
that we call other
things, but our colonies.
I don't think it's been
good for us actually.
But it has been, I would say
on par good for the world,
and I don't really know if you
can be as powerful as we are
or thought we were
without having an empire.
Is that even possible?
I don't know.
Maybe empire is just
an inevitable stage
once you get as rich as we have.
You know, these are
all too deep for me,
but I do know we're about
to see massive change.
- Yeah, and then there's the,
you know, Rome
was an empire too.
All right, let's I know you
got to get back to that little,
you know, highest rated cable,
whatever thing you
got there tonight,
but I wanna give
you one chance to,
is there one particular
essay in here
that you think would be
particularly poignant
that we could just hit on
for just a couple of minutes?
- Well, there's only one
poignant essay in there,
and it was, it's the
last one in the book,
and it was a piece that
I've gone to this, well,
I'll just say it,
I live there now,
the same house, my
whole life in Maine,
and my four kids grew up there.
And maybe 20 years ago, a
little over 20 years ago,
every September we'd
go back to Washington,
we spent the whole summer
there and of course still do.
And, but, you know,
put all the kids in the truck
and drive them
home with the dogs.
And it was always a very sad,
you know, it was always sad,
summer's over, you know?
And one year I wrote
an essay about it,
probably around 2000,
about how nothing in
Maine ever changes.
Like, it's the house
that I grew up in,
that my kids grew up in and,
you know, nothing changes.
Like, there are
things on the shelf
that I put there in
fifth grade, you know,
and it was just like, it
doesn't change, but we change.
And against it's unchanging
nature, we see our own changes.
And it was funny
just this morning.
So I write about in there a
workshop, a shed that we have,
it's been built the 1890s,
and it's just like,
it was a coal shed,
it has a workshop,
'cause things break and
I fix them or whatever.
And they're shelves
along one wall
and my kids when they
were really little,
my oldest is almost 27,
they would put like little
things that they found,
weird colored rocks
or like a rusty anchor
they found at the bottom of the
water or whatever, you know,
broken fishing motors.
And they put them
there as children,
and this was their treasure.
And this morning I was
in there fixing a line,
a rope from a boat,
melting the ends
of nylon boat line.
And I looked over and
there's a rusty anchor that
my almost 27 year old
daughter put there
when she was like five,
and I just felt, you know,
and it'll be there, you know,
when I'm gone and it'll
probably be there,
her grandchildren will see it.
I don't know, there's something,
it's funny how much we
change without perceiving it.
But to have one
constant in your life
against which you can
measure that changes
is really interesting and sad.
- Tucker, I think you've
proven the impossible that
guys on cable lose
are also human beings.
It's wild.
- I'm trying, man,
it's not easy.
- We're going to link to the
book down below, of course,
and I hope I get to see
it, not through these pipes
sometime soon although I suspect
I'm gonna to have to
make it out to Maine
before you make it out to LA.
- That's definitely true.
- See you, man, thanks.
- I appreciate it.
- If you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out the full
episode playlist,
they're both right over here,
and to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.